[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend beginnen wir mit dem blick
nach afghanistan in kabul lässt die
angekündigte präsentation der neuen
taliban regierung weiter auf sich warten
die vielen fraktionen und kriegsherren
unter einen hut zu bringen braucht wohl
noch zeit ein großteil der bevölkerung
wartet ab wie es nun weiter geht viele
sind in einer art schockstarre
aber es gibt auch proteste und
widerstand gegen die neuen herren
während die taliban damit beginnen ihre
öffentlichkeitsarbeit zu
professionalisieren jobbörse berichtet
bilder aus dem staatlichen krankenhaus
in kabul
gefilmt vom chinesischen fernsehen
geübten der verbreitung staatlicher
propaganda china sucht nach guten
kontakten mit dem neuen regime ein
bericht der den taliban gefallen wird
während des politischen wechsels im land
hat das gesundheitssystem speziell
unsere klinik ohne unterbrechung
gearbeitet
kritische patienten wurden rund um die
uhr behandelt vor dem politischen
wechsel aber gab es sehr viele
kriegsopfer auf kabuls mauern in der
innenstadt prangen nun propaganda
sprüche der taliban wir gratulieren euch
zu eurer freiheit liebe landsleute
lautet einer doch diese freiheit gilt
nicht für alle
mädchen und jungen dürfen zwar wieder
zur schule gehen aber erst mal nur bis
zur sechsten klasse zwar durften
lehrerinnen an ihren arbeitsplatz
zurückkehren vielen frauen in anderen
berufen aber wurde das verwehrt dagegen
protestierten frauenorganisationen auch
heute wieder taliban ihr verletzt die
menschenrechte riefen sie
ich will den frauen helfen die bisher
nicht wieder zur arbeit nicht zur schule
gehen durften ich will ihre stimme sein
die polizei trat an um den protest zu
unterbinden eine frau wurde dabei
angeblich verletzt auf dem markt der
geldwechsler sind die männer unter sich
doch das geschäft läuft schlecht die
unsicherheit ist groß wohin das land nun
steuert
die neue regierung sollte frieden und
sicherheit für afghanistan bringen und
es sollte einen waffenstillstand geben
denn noch immer wird gekämpft in den
bergen oberhalb des portals hat sich die
nationale widerstandsfront verschanzt
ein bündnis verschiedener
oppositionsgruppen angeführt von ahmed
massud sohn des 2001 ermordeten
charismatischen warlords ahmed muss auch
von den taliban vertriebene mitglieder
der ehemaligen regierung haben sich den
milizen angeschlossen
wir werden unser land verteidigen der
widerstand geht weiter wir haben viele
taliban getötet sie töteten viele
unserer soldaten wir haben sie gestern
begraben auch heute werden wir wieder
von 23 seiten angegriffen aber wir haben
die situation unter kontrolle
ob sie tatsächlich eine chance haben ist
fraglich sicher ist nur dass die taliban
noch lange nicht alles im griff haben so
wie sie es ihr volk und die welt glauben
machen wollen
darüber waren wir noch mit katrin
eigendorf sprechen die als reporterin
oft für uns in afghanistan war immer
noch viele kontakte in das land hat so
wie man sich das jetzt an guckt
widerstandsfront um panzer und ein ahmad
massud der das anführt kann man auch
sagen geschichte wiederholt sich auch in
afghanistan oder ja damit geht ja auch
im prinzip macht und sohn in diesen
krieg dass er sagt ich trete das erbe
meines vaters an ich bin derjenige der
den widerstand gegen die taliban anführt
wir müssen verhindern dass sich diese
macht hier in diesem land etabliert und
er steht ja auch nicht alleine da er hat
schon eine gewisse front
zusammengekriegt von ehemaligen
regierungs angehörigen der vizepräsident
gehört dazu er hat teile der armee auf
seiner seite und er hat auch die chance
genutzt um waffen zu sammeln also so
ganz harmlos ist diese
widerstandsbewegung sicherlich für die
taliban nicht ich denke das könnte zu
einem problem werden wir müssen halt
abwarten muss steht noch am anfang war
panzer war immer schon auch schon unter
den russen umkämpft also die hatten auch
schon probleme daran zu kommen oder ja
ich meine das ist das große problem was
alle angreifer afghanistans hatte und
was auch immer kriegsentscheidend war
die geografie afghanistans und der so
ein tal beherrscht hat es halt viel
leichter angreifer abzuwehren und das
wird für die taliban schwer sein da rein
zu kommen weil es gibt ja auch keinen
weg so einfach wieder raus
jetzt habe eben in dem bericht auch
gesehen für junge frauen die
protestieren hat das eine chance oder ja
ist das eigentlich verlorene verlorener
mut
also ich denke für die frauen die da in
kabul demonstrieren könnte sich die
situation als ziemlich schwierig
erweisen weil die taliban das haben die
letzten tage und wochen gezeigt sind
schon bereit auch sehr brutal
zurückzuschlagen
also das ist schon ein unglaublicher mut
mit dem die davor gehen aber was man
auch beobachtet ist dass es ziemlich
starke spaltungen inzwischen innerhalb
der taliban bewegung auch gibt es gibt
auch innerhalb der taliban gruppierung
die sagen wir können jetzt nicht einfach
all das was dieses volk im prinzip
errungen hat auf einmal vom tisch fegen
und da sind die frauenrechte ein ein
ganz wichtiger gradmesser das sind sie
übrigens auch in der debatte mit
internationalen geldgebern die für die
taliban sehr wichtig sind also
frauenrechte sind
könnten für die zukunft aller
verhandlungen auch für die zukunft der
macht der taliban eine bedeutende rolle
spielen frauen recht als
verhandlungsmasse
danke katrin für die einschätzung wir
sehen uns sicherlich bald zu dem thema
hier im studio wieder
die bessere lage der menschen in
afghanistan war auch eines der themen
die heute bei der unteilbaren in berlin
eine rolle spielten neben vielen anderen
klimawandel antirassismus soziale
ungerechtigkeiten zu niedrige löhne zu
hohen mieten und vieles mehr
thematisch war sozusagen für jeden etwas
dabei so vielfältig wie die mitglieder
des aktionsbündnisses
unteilbar zu denen um die 350
organisationen die sich unter diesem
titel zusammengeschlossen haben gehören
gewerkschaften
menschenrechtsorganisation oder auch die
frau des future bewegung viele
interessen also viele anliegen stefanie
gosch und nichts schneider berichten
eine gesellschaft die alle mitnimmt die
schwachen schützt und niemanden
diskriminiert fast zu schön um wahr zu
sein die demonstranten in berlin haben
aber konkrete vorstellungen wie man mehr
gerechtigkeit erreichen kann immer
wieder fällt das stichwort löhne wir
haben jetzt in der krise gesehen wer
hier die sache lobt das sind keine
banken sondern das sind die leute die an
der kasse sitzen die in der pflege
arbeiten und wenn die nicht entsprechend
entlohnt werden und gewertschätzt werden
zum beispiel durch lohn dann haben wir
ein problem war ich im gesundheitswesen
arbeitet muss sich da ganz besonders was
ändern denn es kann nicht sein dass
krankenhäuser an die freie wirtschaft
angelehnt sind und wie
wirtschaftsunternehmen arbeiten müssen
ich denke aber auch das ganze personal
in kitas
erzieherin erzieher zum beispiel sind
auch eine ganz wichtige gruppe die mehr
einfach mehr geld für ihre arbeit
kriegen sollten ein riesen thema gerade
in berlin sind auch die mieten bei der
kommenden wahl kann hier auch über ein
volksbegehren abgestimmt werden das
vorsieht große wohnungs konzerne zu
enteignen ich finde schon erschütternd
dass so viele leute sich gedanken machen
müssen ob sie überhaupt in ihrer wohnung
bleiben können also für die muss auf
alle fälle dann auch was gemacht werden
dass alle menschen wohnraum haben den
sie nicht leisten kann und der ihrer
würdig ist und natürlich der klimaschutz
der klimaschutz ja wir haben nur eine
erde und die seite bewohnbar bleiben es
kann nicht sein dass die firmen die die
umweltverschmutzung und die
umweltkatastrophen mit verursachen dass
die kosten das zu beseitigen wieder auf
die normalen bürger abgewälzt wird einen
großteil der demonstranten machen
politische und gesellschaftliche gruppen
aus dem linken spektrum aus bei der
ersten und teilbar demo vor drei jahren
waren noch
240.000 menschen auf die straße gegangen
damals ging es gegen rassismus und
diskriminierung
heute beim thema soziale gerechtigkeit
war es nur ein bruchteil dessen die
polizei spricht von 10.000 der
veranstalter von 30.000 teilnehmern
möglicherweise der pandemie und der
angst vor ansteckung geschuldet kurz vor
den wahlen wollen die organisatorin
aufrütteln wir zeigen dass wir und
taiwan miteinander verbunden sind dass
die zivilgesellschaft ganz klare
forderungen und visionen hat für eine
lebenswerte zukunft für alle menschen
die hier leben die gruppen marschierten
weit auseinandergezogen mit maske das
corona sicherheitskonzept hat nach
angaben der polizei funktioniert
wenn von flüchtlingen die rede ist denkt
man ja vor allem an länder wie syrien
oder afghanistan und natürlich auch an
den afrikanischen kontinent
gewaltige flüchtlingsdramen spielen sich
aber auch noch in ganz anderen
weltregionen ax nur dass man davon in
unseren breitengraden weniger mitbekommt
kolumbien etwa ist eines der länder mit
den weltweit meisten binnenflüchtlingen
durch den jahrzehntelangen bürgerkrieg
sind rund fünf millionen kolumbianer aus
ihren heimatorten geflüchtet
beziehungsweise wurden vertrieben viele
den einmal ruf und land gehörte hausen
bis heute in provisorischen hütten und
zu diesen entwurzelten kommen nun auch
noch jeden tag tausende flüchtlinge aus
dem benachbarten venezuela hinzu unser
südamerika korrespondent christoph
volker rath beginnt seinen bericht in
der grenzstadt cota der kleineren traut
seinen augen kaum endlich eine richtige
mahlzeit war am frisch sauber dass er
und seine vier geschwister gemeinsam mit
mutter emily an einem tisch sitzen und
genug zu essen haben ist etwas ganz
besonderes das rote kreuz hat die
familie aufgenommen in einem stützpunkt
im kolumbianischen code a direkt an der
grenze zu venezuela
vor mehr als zwei jahren sind emily und
ihre kinder aus ihrer heimat geflohen
und doch nie wirklich angekommen
kolumbien kein geld kein dach keine
ahnung wohin
die leute haben zu mir gesagt ich solle
mich prostituieren so viele üble dinge
sogar drogen zu verkaufen haben sie mir
vorgeschlagen aber dafür bin ich nicht
hergekommen ich bin hergekommen um
meinen kindern ein besseres leben zu
ermöglichen
emilys studierte grundschullehrerin doch
das gehalt in venezuela reichte nicht
einmal fürs essen und so nahm sie ihre
kinder und flüchtete es folgen monate
voller not ausbeutung und gefahr erst
als sie nicht mehr weiter weißt schon
zurück nach venezuela will wendet sie
sich ans rote kreuz
[Musik]
an diesem tag hatten meine kinder noch
nichts gegessen ich habe gesagt bitte
helfen sie mir damit meine kinder nicht
hungern müssen stell dir vor dein kind
bitte dich um essen und du hast nur ein
paar cent in der tasche
auf dauer hier bleiben können sie nicht
das rote kreuz und andere organisationen
können hier im grenzgebiet nur nothilfe
leisten der strom der flüchtlinge reißt
nicht ab
wir haben diese unterkunft erst vor drei
tagen eröffnet und in diesen drei tagen
schon 40 personen aus zehn familien
aufgenommen das zeigt dass der bedarf
hier sehr groß ist
mehr als zwei millionen flüchtlinge aus
venezuela sind allein in kolumbien
unterwegs in der grenzstadt kokott
tummeln sich tausende gestrandete
geschäftemacher und menschen die nur
kurz über die grenze kommen um sich bei
einer hilfsorganisation medizinisch
behandeln zu lassen
die meisten aber ziehen weiter sowie
johanna die mit ihrem mann und einem
freund unterwegs ist sie will bis nach
peru erzählt sie uns denn sie ist
schwanger und ihr kind soll auf keinen
fall bier zur welt kommen für mein kind
ist der bauch das sicherste
transportmittel
von hier bis zu ihrem ziel sind es noch
mehr als 3000 kilometer
die verzweiflung scheint manchmal größer
als die entfernungen auf diesem
kontinent
und jetzt die nachrichten
zunächst zur krone situation in
deutschland die zahl der neuinfektionen
ist weiter angestiegen das
robert-koch-institut erfasste 10
1835 neuinfektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind 532 mehr als am
vergangenen samstag weitere 24
todesfälle wurden gemeldet die sieben
tage incidents liegt bei
80,7
angesichts der stockenden impfungen in
deutschland werden warnungen vor einer
kritischeren coroner lage in den
kommenden monaten lauter mediziner
befürchten im herbst eine erneute starke
belastung der intensivstationen sollte
das im tempo nicht schnell anziehen
gesundheitsminister spahn rief erneut
dazu auf im angebote wahrzunehmen
vollständig geimpft sind laut spahn in
deutschland rund 51 millionen menschen
und damit etwa 61 prozent der
bevölkerung
nach der machtübernahme der taliban in
kabul haben sich auch mindestens fünf
hochrangige politiker aus afghanistan
nach deutschland abgesetzt das meldet
der spiegel unter den mehr als 4.500
ausgeflogenen sind nach angaben von
bundesinnenminister seehofer bislang 20
sicherheitsrelevante fälle bekannt
darunter sind auch verurteilte
straftäter und offenbar
terrorverdächtige
der streik der gewerkschaft deutscher
lokomotivführer ging heute weiter kritik
am verhalten der gdl kam vom chef des
deutschen gewerkschaftsbundes hoffmann
er bemängelte in der rheinischen post
dass die gdl einzelinteressen über das
gesamtinteresse alle anderen
bahnbeschäftigten stelle um die
auswirkungen des streiks abzumildern
will die bahn an diesem wochenende die
kapazitäten im fernverkehr erhöhen und
rund 30 prozent des normalen fahrplan
anbieten enden soll der arbeitskampf
laut gdl ankündigung am dienstag um 2
uhr und
die leute zahlen dieses samstags sie
lauten wie immer ohne gewähr
25 15 20 39 44 superzahl 7 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 6 die
wetteraussichten für morgen noch im
norden teils zäher hochnebel der sich im
tagesverlauf aber meist auflöst sonst
sonnig oder nur locker bewölkt im
bergland ganz vereinzelt gewittrige
schauer möglich höchstwerte 19 bis 28
grad die weiteren aussichten auch in den
nächsten tagen ruhiges spätsommerwetter
mit einer mischung aus sonne wolken und
nebel sowie höchsttemperaturen zwischen
20 und 29 grad
ja und um diesen sommerlichen
samstagabend schön abzurunden gibt es
jetzt noch das sportstudio und danach so
gegen 0 uhr gibt es die nächste heute
express sondern auch wiedersehen
wiedersehen
[Musik]